JANET RANKIN: Another
active learning technique
that can be very, very
effective in supporting
student learning is the jigsaw.
And it gets its name from
the activity involved
when you do a jigsaw puzzle.
And usually, most people
when they do a jigsaw
will look for the--
they'll find all
the edge pieces,
or they'll find all
the blue pieces,
or they'll find
all the pieces that
have a certain image on them.
You do the homogeneous
aspects of the exercise.
So you get all the edge
pieces, the blue pieces,
the particular image pizzas.
But eventually, you have
to take those pieces
and put them together.
You have to link
them up with pieces
that don't look quite
like those pieces,
so that's the heterogeneous
component of it.
And so what you
do in a jigsaw is
you ask students to become
experts, if you will,
homogeneous experts,
in a particular area,
on a particular topic.
And you can do this by giving
them a reading in class,
or you can do this by asking
them to reflect on something
that you've addressed
in a previous class
or that they've addressed
in a previous homework.
But they sit together,
or they group
together in this, what
I call, homogeneous
group, where everyone is talking
about the same particular
topic.
And they just discuss that
topic and they become experts
in that homogeneous topic.
And then you can have three
or four different topics,
whatever, depending on
the size of the class.
And you have these
local groups of experts,
like the edge pieces, and the
blue pieces, and the picture
pieces.
And then after giving them
a period of time, maybe five
minutes, 10 minutes,
depending on the class,
you break them up into
heterogeneous groups.
So you get one with one
representative from Group A,
goes with one
representative from Group B,
and one representative
from Group C,
from group D.
And now you have a new
heterogeneous group that has
an A, a B, a C, and a D in it.
Or if we use the
puzzle analogy, you
have a group that has
some person that's
the edge expert, some person
that's the picture expert,
and some person that's
the blue piece expert.
And they're all in a group.
And now they share what
they know individually
with each other and then
they combine that expertise,
they synthesize that expertise,
to make something bigger
to come up with a more global
understanding of the problem.
And then each group does
that in their own way.
So the heterogeneous groups then
form a more holistic, or a more
heterogeneous, solution
to the problem,
as if they're putting together
the different kinds of puzzle
pieces.
And then again, as with
the other activities,
we ask them to then report out.
Before that I usually
will circulate in the room
the same way I do
with the pair share
to hear what each of
the groups are saying,
to see if any groups are
having particular issues,
or if they have some
particular breakthroughs that I
want to make sure they share
with the class as a whole.
There are some
logistical issues.
One, you want to make sure that
the students really can become
these homogeneous experts.
So that if you have a
group of four people,
that they've all really come
up to speed on the topic.
So ideally, you would give
a pre-class assignment
and you'd say, yes.
I need everybody to
read this article
and to be able to explain
this point, this point,
and this point, and
you would assign that
to that particular
group of students.
And then you'd do the same
with a few other topics.
You're assuming then that the
students have read the paper,
or have read the
article, whatever
it is you want them to read,
and that they understand it
to the level that you
hope they understood it.
Sometimes you don't have
time for that or it just
doesn't work out,
so you give them
something to read within class.
And again, that can be tricky.
Students may not have the
same level of understanding,
so groups may be a
little bit spotty.
The other thing that can
happen with the jigsaw, which
is a really silly problem but
sometimes it just trips you
up, is if you have, depending
on the number of students,
you have to kind of
think on your feet
about how many students are
in the homogeneous group
versus how many students are
in the heterogeneous group.
If it's a perfect
square, it works fine.
So if you've got nine students,
or 16 students, or 25 students,
you know you have five
groups in one situation
and then five groups in
the other, that means you
have to have the same number of
groups as heterogeneous topics.
So if I went A, B, C, D, I
have to then have four groups
because I had to have four A's,
four B's, four C's, and four
D's.
So sometimes just the number
of topics and the number
of students that you
have in your class
makes it kind of
hard to make groups
that don't have extra
people or aren't short
a particular expert.
And that's just something
you want to plan beforehand.
And if somebody
doesn't come to class,
if you know you have 25 students
in your class and someone
doesn't show up, then you
have to kind of deal with it
on the fly.
But that can be the trickiest
thing with the jigsaw,
is just getting the
number of students right.